стоять публіці ваші учні вами кубачі
я захотіла нації ми любимо ці чотири
омити ми їх то боязкістю школу там і що
люблять знаходитесь фактично назву чайному
пирскаю лінії фронту які за жир мови it
що може ранок ptv ситуація безтурботна для
жике амвон і нас правді творять школу для
дітей
додати проходиш закону була вся база
школи та
школа стала наполегливою і суди в дусі друза
ти так вже дітей день шишки з гілок і
правди не бачу боїться у колекції
вода-то повсюди я кисну світла українською
дітям і затвердить їх в тому, що ви на
своєї нарядної землі та
для нас би стіна робота в мешканця самі
тут на території лінія роздування та
зуби його складне з точки зору bespeco
і із . за готову
яким чином виймають затвердив це у дітях
і так вже зовнішніх бочках привнести в
тому що сьогодні ми ж стій лимони
свою владу над лижну державу битий стоячи
і мухіт нескладні кохані та прийому війна
непу виносу брат йому живицю дітей гострим
це отрута з мою свиту
там у нас важливі в Петро і мати
такі школи за крима
сам йти біля кореня школи говоритиму під
році ти сагід і майк ніби кращий за
зносини і прошу chirkova допомога
я козу крима вигляд уряду пішла на
місіонери і він та мої butter треба на
флешку черву наполегливим школам для
покращення матеріально-технічні бази c
кабінети фізики хімії біології комп'ютер
не класи для того ще де ти реально
отруювали в добре розуму ви почали
прям то вам і поскрипували зі штатом з
приводу на ваті тиаго початковому руку
аджи самість його навчив руку будуть
навчать через уловлені програми та
підходом і початку у школі і я беру
виливаємо штирів бульово я затягну
у нас правді тут у них наш краще мало
смирно рясно ситуації вікі мужик нам
хитки на сидить і